we're now learning about the next phase
of obstruction of the house committee
investigating the january 6 trump riots
and it just doesn't stop every week we
learn about something like this the new
one is that john eastman that's the
lawyer who wrote the memo
explaining how
maybe mike pence could overturn the
election results that guy john eastman
is now blocking 3 200 trump-related
documents from the house january 6th
committee as reported by cnn
meanwhile
business insider is reporting that
eastman is refusing to hand over 37 000
pages of emails to the capital riot
committee so let's go through what's
going on john eastman a far-right lawyer
for then-president donald trump who
wanted to block his electoral loss in
2020 is withholding about 3 200
documents from the house select
committee investigating the riots
eastman previously was ordered by the
court to turn over 101 documents after
claiming some were confidential legal
communications since he's continued to
work through a hundred thousand pages of
emails from his chapman university
account
that the house committee wants at this
time eastman is arguing that the
thousands of documents comprising about
37 36 000 pages
should stay confidential federal judge
david carter may continue to weigh
whether he can keep those pages secret
uh meanwhile
john eastman is refusing to hand over 37
000 pages of emails to the committee he
says they're shielded by attorney-client
privilege a judge is weighing the
argument eastman is known for writing a
memo detailing how trump could overturn
the 2020 election
i think at this point
we should never again be subjected to a
single word about hillary's emails we
should never again be
held
and brutally pummeled with the idea that
democrats don't handle data correctly
they don't handle information correctly
or any of it now i will be subjected to
that you will be subjected to that we
all are going to be subjected to that
but we really shouldn't have to and the
strategy at this point is abundantly
clear they are trying to run the clock
out on the january 6th investigation and
they indeed may succeed that's the
saddest part
i have read a bunch of legal opinions
about the strategy
and
whether it's a moral strategy or not
whether it is ultimately
legal that they can just refuse to turn
stuff over
by the time it's adjudicated republicans
may have control of the house and this
investigation will be done so and
there's really not that much that can be
done about it um that seems to be the
strategy because republicans have made
it very clear
if they take control of the house in
november
and and are sworn into that control in
january of 2023 which is how it works
this investigation is over and i believe
they will almost certainly at least
attempt impeachment proceedings of
president joe biden i don't think they
will go anywhere but i think that they
will attempt it they're telling us
they're going to attempt it many of them
are and i believe them
and this is why they are stalling in
this way if they if the circumstances
were different
where there were going to be if there
was a guarantee
of not another what is it nine months of
democratic control
but rather two years and nine months as
an example
a lot of these people that are very
clearly just obstructing at this point
in time and spending tons of legal
dollars trying to avoid disclosing
information
likely wouldn't be doing it because that
timeline two years and nine months
versus just nine months would almost
certainly lead to a bunch of this stuff
being forced to be turned over to the
january 6 committee because that's what
the last year has shown us
much of the many of these challenges to
try to prevent documents from being
given turned over to the january 6
committee ultimately a judge says you
got to give him the information we've
seen it with trump we've seen it with
others ultimately
kimberly guilfoyle ends up in sitting
with the committee and whatever else
but at this point they have nine months
and really six and a half
until the election takes place my
instinct is that if indeed republicans
win in november that period between
november and january i don't know how
much investigation is going to take
place then so in some real sense
if we want to be conservative about it
democrats have
like until october to get this done
that's now five and a half months away
the running out the clock strategy does
seem to make sense and by the way this
is going to keep happening until there's
actually consequences for it
um why wouldn't they just dig their
heels in and refuse to comply because
trump's entire presidency was what are
you going to do about it what are you
going to do about it yes i said i was
going to disassociate from my businesses
and i didn't and i made 1.6 billion
while i was president and my kids made
hundreds of millions and ivanka was
sitting in for my secretary of state at
a meeting and
i can't even give you the full list of
stuff and it's been so so the hell what
because there have been no consequences
whatsoever and i will take it an even
step further
i don't even know how much this
committee ultimately matters
the committee of course if they find
evidence of criminality they they can
and they must refer it to the department
of justice as of right now
there's no evidence that the department
of justice under merit garland
is genuinely willing to bring charges
against any of these people
i'm not saying joe biden should get
involved he shouldn't
as i've said many times before biden
should have no involvement in saying to
the justice department investigate here
find charges here absolutely not but put
joe biden take joe biden out of this
because he's not even involved
there is no evidence that merrick
garland and his justice department are
really willing to even consider doing
what are admittedly politically very
difficult things when it comes to the
failed former president and his
administration so of course republicans
are doing what they're doing
why wouldn't they
i love documentaries and i bet many of
you do as well and for documentaries i
go to curiosity one of our sponsors it's
an app for your phone tablet tv like
netflix or hulu
except
curiositystream has a way better
selection of documentaries because
curiositystream only has documentaries
that's what they specialize in if you
were looking for the new award-winning
documentary they have it if you're
looking for classic documentaries they
have those they have a ton of great
original content always adding more to
the catalog i just watched
zenith which is about the latest
advancements in space travel a topic i'm
super interested in but there's
documentaries about just about every
topic imaginable i've been a curiosity
stream subscriber for several years now
it's my favorite app on my roku and the
best part of curiosity stream it's 15
bucks a year
at curiositystream.com
pacman and the link is down below